hey y'all time for the movie
retrospective yeah this is a good one
this is yeah this was a good one this
was one that Sophie sent us she sent us
like the special edition era blu-ray and
I had heard of this movie probably
through the damned song you have a song
called psycho mania which is about this
but I had actually never got around to
seeing it even though I'm kind of into a
lot of British cinema from around this
time period yeah it was 1973 don't
expect a modern movie that's not what
you're talking about here you know I
mean it's a I guess you could call it
kind of like a paranormal thriller that
involved British bikers yeah and it's
got like some 60s [ __ ] music and
stuff in it it sounds like cream I'm at
any moment unexpected you know there's
no white room going on you know and
there it's about some bikers about a
biker who his mom is a famous psychic I
guess and he finds out a way through her
to bring himself back from the dead he
teaches it to his [ __ ] gang yeah it's
weird a bunch of British bikes there
they look like some of her triumphs some
of them look like there might be a BSA
it's hard to tell you don't show the
labels they were supposed to be like
really cool Harley's you know when they
first ready but they couldn't afford the
British bikes that were available in
that area at the time they're pretty
beat up and they got some cheesy the
helmets with skulls on you know but it's
just part of the it's part of this movie
it's part of the character of this movie
there is something really indescribable
charming about this movie um and I'm not
really I can't really put my finger on
what it is I should say that like the
helmets that they wear and it's like in
all the posters and stuff like that but
it's like a helmet and then it's got
like a white visor type of thing which I
guess is supposed to look like skull
eyes yeah it's so it's a regular clear
visor that they painted white a white
skull pattern on it yeah which you know
I ride and I don't I don't know how you
can see through those you know yes they
did if they were riding on him it was
like the way it looked too reminded me a
little bit of phantom of the paradise
exactly thing that he was
I think phantom of the Paradise might
have actually omage that slightly i
wonder or i wonder your incidence now
this came out in 72 or 73 yeah and I
can't remember what your phantom of the
paradise game right I know we reviewed
it but I can't run off the top fan of
the Paradise is better but it's a
different kind of movie that's a rock
opera yeah I don't know so well this one
is kind of like this one is different
yeah it's kind of like a rock biker
underground a cult movie in a weird way
it kind of made me kind of reminded me
of the movie the legacy which is another
American British made movie yeah yeah I
can see what you I can see kinda feel a
little bit like a legacy it had a little
bit of that kind of vibe but then it
also kind of had a vibe of like I don't
want to say like an American 60s biker
flick you know like if some of the ones
had been on MST like wild rebels and
that kind of stuff it had like a little
bit of that but it's a very very British
like sensibility so it also has and some
of the actors that were in it like I
think Nicky Henson who plays the main
character I think he was in like some of
the other like kind of big British
horror that I like which find her
general and those types of movies so it
has that kind of like a cult thing too
which i think is what makes it more
interesting to me it almost feels like a
vampire movie it is kind of yes you
mentioned now that you mention it it
almost feels like a vampire movie yeah
it's just a weird movie and the thing is
is that when they made this thing they
didn't think much of it they thought
this is this is just bulk moviemaking
yeah and the people that made it even
the actors and everything they just
thought it would just come and go and be
forgotten in it they didn't think this
movie would be anything but it became a
cult classic it's very funny because
when you watch the movie because I and I
think we probably mentioned this before
maybe unlike some other movie reviews
but I feel like the UK has like a much
more they have like that more of a
like a respect for the craft of acting
so like a lot of their actors like
started on the stage and things like
that and then later they could maybe
your movie yeah so it's like it's the
same thing with like all of the people
that were in this movie were stage
actors first and some of them were quite
established and had been around for like
a really long time
some of them like Nicky Henson who was
like the main you know gank the gang
leader or whatever he was later he was
in Downton Abbey later on and [ __ ] like
that so it's like these people have been
around for a really long time and but
when they were making this movie they
just felt like well it's just like a
throwaway movie it's just like some
cheap Jack kind of movie that no one's
gonna see or that people are gonna see
and forget about like a year from now
and they all seemed genuinely delighted
and bemused at that snow but it happened
yeah well they thought you know they
thought it would just be forgotten
they thought it was silly when they were
making it yeah but they didn't know that
it would end up on television yeah this
is before the advent of things ended up
on television and in terms of England
they were used to that evidently they
weren't used to the idea called
syndication but it ended up on
television and it got a huge audience
overtime of kids that grew up seeing
this and it influenced them you know in
terms of the motorcycle scene and
everything motorcycle scene rock scene
everything yeah I think what ended up
happening with this one in the UK was
that because it was a cheap movie to
acquire the rights to and also because
it doesn't have like any nudity it's not
it's got violence but it's not like
bloody or gory or anything yeah so I
feel like it was on TV a lot like so Ian
yeah so it got played like a lot like on
late-night British TV like over and over
again so I read one article that said
this actually might be the most viewed
b-movie in British history because it
just was on all the time so there's like
a whole generation of people who grew up
like seeing this movie over and over
again and you know as they got older
like this whole cult developed around it
the funny thing about biker movies from
the 60s and the 70s is that they're
trying to make these really
outrageous rebel outlaw movies but
because of censorship problems they
couldn't really show any crimes being
committed a lot of times yeah they could
only kind of hint that something
happened maybe so you headed up with
something that in a way was kind of
milquetoast the one that kind of broke
the mold going back I think the first
biker movie that was actually violent
and for real I think when mad at Max one
Mad Max one had some violence in it
there's mostly wrecks and dudes flying
yeah
but there were also rapes and [ __ ]
involved even they didn't show it but
they let you know that that did happen
and there they even in fur in Mad Max
one that the biker men were raping other
men but they didn't actually show it
remember the scene where they're out in
the middle of town and the two guys are
like they ran after the guy and he ran
inside that's what they were trying to
hint at you know now I will I will say
though that one of the movies that was
on one of the biker movies that was on
MST I believe it was the sidehackers
that actually did show I think it was
the sidehackers
that actually did show a fairly violent
rape and murder of a woman and that was
60 early 60s okay I can't really
remember when that was and I'm pretty
sure it was sidehackers was it British
no it was American American okay but um
you know so so it was like a thing but I
can see what you're saying because they
think it seems like a lot of teen movies
a lot of biker movies a lot of those
kind of like B movies yeah we're pretty
tame actually um in in regards to the
violence and stuff this is too but for
some reason it's not to its detriment um
the most violent thing is really that
happens in this movie is that a woman
kills a baby by running over it with her
motorcycle but while she's like in
Astoria yeah but really that's what
happens but what you actually see is her
hit a stroller and then fall off the
motorcycle because it hits the other
side of the like she hits the freezer
and and you
there's no baby in the stroller you
don't I mean it's just the ideas the
ideas the suggestion Road I have to say
though that one of the coolest things
about this movie the stunt work is great
there's like a really lot of good for
what for what they were doing yeah they
were ramping and they were running in
round in traffic on motorcycles they did
they showed some wrecks but that was
also they hinted that there was a wreck
yeah and you know the special features
they show like a part where you see a
guy on a motorcycle hit a truck
broadside and he flies through it yeah
but when they actually show you what you
really saw you saw a guy just jumping
out of truck but you know jumping out
this side of a chart on the side of
truck through a fake sidewall and then
somebody threw a with a tire or
something it was just all done in the
Edit but see that's bad yeah yeah it's
able to suggest to you that that's what
happened yeah you thought I saw that
yeah I did too but that's not what
that's not what I saw um I do have to
say I was very impressed by the the
stunts of like the guy falling off there
jumping off the overpass that's good
that looks really good that looks like
yeah now some of that was really
somebody jumping off a real overpass I
think yeah and some of it was a dummy I
think it was when he fell off the
overpass I mean from what I could gather
from cuz we watched all the special
features that was a real stunt guy
jumping off mean obviously there were
mattresses and stuff down there like
they weren't gonna just let him fall in
the road but when the body hit the truck
which they showed briefly I'm you know
obviously I think that was a dummy and
then they showed him like underneath the
truck but that looked really good so I
think that that was like realistic I
don't think it was a dummy like at the
top I think that was a real guy and I
think that was a real overpass all in
all the movie kind of comes across as
being like Mad Max 1 had a baby with the
legacy it's like magic if Mad Max one
had villains who are stylish like
British people including cute girls
alright and they've they're riding
around on British motorcycles there
there is some and they're committing
crimes and there
themselves sort of this weird [ __ ]
happens in it and it's an occult
movie it's like an occult biker had an
occult biker thriller yes I would call
it with action but it doesn't quite have
the action of Mad Max one that doesn't
have the the racks yeah but you don't
really need it it didn't need it I like
the story well yeah I mean I liked the
whole like creepy occult yeah aspect of
it because you don't really see a lot of
like biker movies though that have that
kind of angle to them and I thought that
was really well handled like you know
what I mean what the whole just the
whole concept of Tom Latham who is the
you know the the head of the biker gang
which is called the Living Dead by the
way that was prescient
yeah they're all wearing their jackets
and all their names are painted on it
and it's pretty [ __ ] their colors are
painted on the back of the jacket and it
looks it looks mainstream and very tame
by today's standards but I guess that
pride looked cool is [ __ ] back in west
72 right yeah like yeah they're all
frightening the square now it's kind of
come back around being kind of cool in a
in an ironic sort of way but it is a
good movie and the guy what was the lead
the leads name again which the character
name of the actor named the actor named
Nicky Hansen Nicky Hansen yeah he looks
great in his leathers and and he does a
good job at playing this character
all in all he comes across as a vampire
really and he did most of his own stunts
because he was actually I mean he said
that the reason that he had wanted to do
this movie in particular was because he
was like a motorcycle rider and he was
like a huge junkie about it and they
said like even all the paint like the
motorcycle pants and all the [ __ ] that
he wore that was like all his [ __ ] like
it wasn't a costume that was the stuff
that you normally work but um yeah so
what I was gonna say it was I really
liked the whole aspect of you know this
gang and then Tom Latham who's kind of
like this rich guy and he finds out that
his psychic mom and the butler Shadwell
which we'll get into that in a little
bit but that they somehow know the
secret of immortality so you can
essentially like kill yourself and
you'll just come back
from the dead if you not not like a
zombie you'll just be like your regular
self kind of like a vampire but you
don't have to drink blood but yeah but
you come back as like essentially
immortal and indestructible yeah so you
know once he gets like all the rest of
the gang like on board with it and
they're all like oh well [ __ ] well sign
us up and so they all like off
themselves too but you have to believe
it's like it's really so there's like a
really weird sequence like at the
beginning because I guess I guess the
implication and I don't remember if they
said this directly in the movie or not I
guess the implication was that his mom
had committed suicide and come back I
think because they said the dad did it
but he didn't believe hard enough so the
dad didn't come back yeah I didn't
really catch that boy cuz remember he
like went into that weird room that's
like the green wallpaper and that was
the mirror and the Frog and let all that
really weird like imagery because he was
talking about the secret that she had
yeah that's must been what he was
talking about so I so I didn't really
catch it until I thought about it later
on I was like oh I guess they're not
immortal must be immortal too because
they had it was you know another thing
they implied too was that they had made
like a deal with Satan right because
yeah cuz what happens at the end like
you know that she's like had to cash in
or deal like to stop the Sun or whatever
and um you know everybody gets turned
into frogs turn to stones whatever like
all this other kind of crazy [ __ ]
happens it's a weird movie you guys but
um but there's just something I don't
know it's like this just as indefinable
I don't know if it's just because I
really like British movies from that
time period and I really like these kind
of seventies occult movies like I've
always really liked that that whole vibe
the Satanism seances and all that kind
of [ __ ] but this one really I found this
one really really entertaining and like
you know like all the acting was good
because like I said these were all stage
actors and a lot of them are still
around like today and you know have been
in like real big stuff like but the sad
thing about this and I don't know how
much psycho mania had to do do with this
but the guy that played Shadwell the
butler mmm um that was George Sanders
and he had had like a huge career prior
to this and he was in like some big
movies he was in like the he was
Rebeca like I think like the Alfred
Hitchcock movie he was in [ __ ] All
About Eve he was unlike us so he was in
some big like deal like oscar-winning
type of [ __ ] and this was his last movie
and legend has it that he was in Madrid
and he saw a preview of this movie that
he was in and went back to his hotel
room and committed suicide yeah because
and they had like on all the extras they
said like what his note said it wasn't
super long it didn't like reference the
movie or anything but it just said
something like I'm so bored or something
like that or this place it sucks and you
have fun guys yeah essentially so our
good luck good luck at the end so so
people don't know if it was just because
he was getting old that he was over it
or he just saw the movie and he's like
this is how low my career has sunk you
know I mean just because he'd been in so
many like classic movies prior and then
maybe he just thought I'm in this piece
of [ __ ] I don't know but maybe it didn't
have maybe it didn't have anything to do
with it maybe it was just like a
coincidence piece of [ __ ] movie there
really wasn't and it's like it's just
funny it was funny to me that all the
actors that were in it and I think this
happens a lot with cult movies because
when you're working on something
particularly back in the 60s or 70s when
people didn't really have that much of a
concept of like a midnight movie or an
underground movie or a cult classic or
anything like that you didn't really
have that concept yet like solidified so
when you're just working on this movie
that you think is just this [ __ ] I
thought it was a weird yeah they said it
you know it took like 2 or 3 weeks to
make it it's like they got like a few
hundred bucks or something I think Nicky
Benson said he got well like 150 pounds
or so like that should be in [ __ ]
[ __ ] I remember it was like some like
ridiculously small amount and he's like
you know it was just like this one-off
thing we were just doing it for some
money it's like he's like I you know it
was out of season for the theater cuz he
was actually like a you know in the
theater so he got paid weekly doing that
but he was just like I you know I was on
a break and I needed some extra cash so
I just did this and he's like and now 40
years later people are coming up to him
and like wanting him to sign stuff like
you know sign my psycho baby a poster
and all this other kind of stuff and
he's just thinks it's the most hilarious
thing ever because he's not everyone he
thought everyone would just forget it
yeah and nobody did so it's just very
funny to me but in some ways I think
that that kind of helped it out because
they weren't really trying to make
anything that was going to like stand
the test of time or still be talked
about 4050 years later it just kind of
happened yeah according to according to
the people that were involved in the
movie the success this movie was an
accident yeah everything everything
about it that made it successful was an
accident yeah and and was not really
planned and they just they were just did
the best job they could with what they
had and they gave it a good score and
they did but it was just a very standard
piece of solid work everybody just did
their good a good job on it but what
they were working with wasn't much even
in terms of script and budget it was
just a you know a few days work yeah
that's all and they thought it would
just be forgotten they didn't really
think much of it then they moved on to
the next project I know and that's it it
kills me because that's just so funny to
think about I think that happens like I
said Percy Lee in the 60s and 70s with a
lot of these movies is that the actors
that are in them you know for them it's
just a paycheck or such a job like well
I'll just you know you know they're on
their way to like work in like bigger
movies it's like here's another thing
that I do for a month or two and then I
got to move on to the next thing and
then 40 years later they're in a horror
convention with like twenty five year
old kids like coming up to them like you
know quite the quote in the movie Adam
and [ __ ] like that and it's just like it
must be the weirdest thing ever and
what's funny is that the fans of the
movies over the ages have blown the
significance of the movie way out of
proportion like it had songs in the
movie that had lyrics and because it was
in a motorcycle it was in a motorcycle
style movie people thought that those
were some kind of traditional motorcycle
songs that had like I'm the meaning
behind them you know cultural
significance in the motorcycle scene but
it didn't they were just random songs
they put in there and they they became
meaning for over the years because we
were growing up seeing it yeah
and people were reading into things you
know whenever they saw the movie because
they thought the movie was a lot more
significant and better planned out than
it really was so the audience is inter
and the audience's interpretation of
what's going on is far more important
than what actually went on in the damn
movie yeah because they weren't trying I
mean they were trying to make a good
movie but they weren't trying to like
make something that would be like a cult
classic yeah that well-regarded
yeah it was not of any kind of cultural
significance it wasn't a product of the
underground that had like a deep meaning
but evidently other people watching I
thought it did but it didn't well it was
an accident
yeah it was just a fun biker cross with
a cult movie that had like some really
good stunts and it really good acting
yeah I was laughing about the song
because there was an interview with the
guy that did the score like for the you
know for the movie
John Tamara and I think his name was and
they were talking about the song that's
in it that gets played at Tom Latham's
funeral which we have to talk about that
too cuz Sophie asked me about that but
um that song riding free which is just
it's kind of a terrible song but also
kind of awesome and a terrible kind of
folk it's a song well we kind of like
kind of made jokes about like when it
came on I'm like yes and it's just like
the cheesy words about you know being a
motorist like this be like oh yeah and
ride routes I'm like I feel like real
bikers wouldn't want like that hippy
[ __ ] played it therefore you know I you
know I'm doing but that you know not
during that time that time the United
States were bikers were listening to
would have been Steppenwolf
yeah that was just a lot darker a lot
darker sounding this is literally sound
like John Denver singing it did yeah
rocky man hi Colorado yeah it sounded
like that well it's funny because um
another thing so so Sophie asked us
about this she's like I couldn't wait to
hear what you guys said about the Tom
Latham funeral cuz all the bikers like
go to the mom's house and the mom knows
that he's gonna come back from the dead
so it's like she's not like sad about
anything and the other bikers are like
well we want to have the funeral the way
you know he would have wanted it and
she's like yeah whatever you know to do
whatever you want
and so they dig this like big square
hole and then they put him in it like
dead sitting up on his motorcycle or the
helmet but he doesn't but his head
doesn't go all the way above the ground
I understand how that was gonna be so
say they're gonna they gonna like bury
him up to his neck or what are we doing
I said are we gonna put like a cairn
over it or something like a pile of
rocks er but no then the next thing you
know they just show him buried I guess
they just put a mile there well like I
said it didn't really matter cuz well
the bikers didn't know that he was
coming back from the dead but his mom
knew and then later on you see him just
rocketing out of the damn ground in
broad daylight on that motorcycle and it
looked just like I said man they got
that from the cover that meat loaf album
yeah better meat out of hell either that
or Meat Loaf got it from the boys yeah
went about it I don't know but I think I
want to take 71 but maybe it was but
yeah it's like and another thing that I
thought was kind of funny even though
like I said I I actually really loved
this movie and I was surprised that I
had never seen it because I you know see
a lot seen a lot of other British horror
movies from around that time period but
uh one thing that did kind of make me
laugh was that so here's a biker gang of
these hooligans and these terror ways
these tow rags and they they discover
the secret the secret to life after that
you can kill yourself and if you believe
hard enough you'll come back from the
dead and you'll be indestructible like
you said like a vampire except you don't
have to drink blood so it's like and you
can still go around in the daytime so
it's like being a vampire without any of
the drawbacks yeah so they do that and
then all they can think of to do is like
ride their motorcycles through
supermarkets and like knock over baby
carriages and just ride around people
and have everyone go oh well beat people
up beating people up and stuff like that
I'm like this is what you're gonna do
with your immortality and
all right yeah but I just kind of like
that baby laughs and it's like that's
all they could think of to do like I
said that movie was not thought out well
it was just some quick thing that they
knocked out to have a product and it's
stuck
get on TV kids grew up watching and they
liked it yeah you know I really like to
do I just I thought it was super fun and
actually I kind of want to kind of want
to watch it again well when it when it
was written I guess it was first written
under the title the Living Dead which
like I said that's what the gang was
called and I love that there is another
another alternate title of it is the
death wheelers which i think is very
funny
well if you like if you like Mad Max one
you might like this one what else like I
said if you like british movies from
this even if you like some of the folk
horror stuff like I said like
Witchfinder general or you know Wicker
Man or something like that because it
definitely has that type of vibe to it
um but then it also has like a stunt
like biker type of veneer to it but it
has like a real occult and it has like
some really weird like I said when he
goes in that room and like the mirror
and there's like a big frog in the
mirror and it's just kind of like I
don't know if like the frogs was through
the devil or it's like the
representation this is a whole frog
thing yeah didn't make you sense me out
but it doesn't have to make sense it was
just like trippy and weird it would it
reminded me a lot of the legacy yeah it
had a very similar vibe to that so
that's like actually a good call like
what you know where it was just kind of
this creepy creepy paranormal paranormal
which is what are the Living Dead type
thing with witches and in inside
expensive houses doing seances and crap
and yeah [ __ ] happens but in this case
it's it's a motorcycle gang do yeah so
this might be I mean you know I'm sure
there's probably other ones because I
haven't seen every movie ever made but
this seems like one of the very few
movies that had that particular
juxtaposition or that kind of crossover
and I think it was kind of a good call
you know what I mean so it was like kind
of a teen biker movie and one according
to the star
the only reason why he accepted it is
because he opened up the page and it
said that he would be riding and some
and some and some stretched and it's
stretched chopped Harley drag bikes yes
not the way they were riding oh yeah
I'll be in it cuz he rode his I want to
be I want to be in the movie but when he
got there it's a bunch of like a Triumph
Bonneville and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
he's like what happened Harley like we
can't afford Harley's yeah he's like so
basically they had eight bikes and I
think it was like we got him all like
secondhand he's like they probably got
him all for ten pounds each other yeah
they had to have a whole fleet of
mechanics like to keep from running yeah
breaking down yeah and it's you know
looking at him looking back at those
motorcycles seeing the way they were in
the 70s boy they were shitty just
rickety looking things you know well
everything was kind of [ __ ] everything
was yeah everything is shitty you kind
of forget like the newer versions of the
Triumph Bonneville are [ __ ]
lightyears ahead of what the 70s
versions but it was kind of like that
with the Harley's to a bit yeah drum
brakes and [ __ ] like that yeah
everything was crappy back then that's
what I mean it seems like that that's
why I never buy like old people they're
also in the back of my days but no it
really wasn't everything was like crappy
and not really yeah not really well
it's like shit's much much better back
looking more thought-out nowadays yeah I
mean it's something else when you know
[ __ ] nineteen [ __ ] sixties
nineteen [ __ ] 64 65 Mustang Cobra or
Mustang GT or something it just gets its
ass beat by a [ __ ] that damn what's
that [ __ ] stupid ass looking car that
little cube car ok a square Vance with a
little Scion van yeah is that what that
is yeah you know a little Scion yeah
Vance will just [ __ ] tear up a muscle
car of the [ __ ] seventies well yeah
just beat it and everywhere in every
acid every respect and your faster
better turn and quicker better stop and
just everything get on you just you
forget that's what I mean cars back in
the seventies were sitting poor terrible
terrible there [ __ ] is super heavy
didn't make any [ __ ] didn't make
there we go rattle traps a lot of didn't
have any [ __ ] seatbelt sir yeah I
used to try though
I forgot what it was like driving is
like driving a boat yeah go run turn and
a [ __ ] car would someone like that
take forever or to settle down like a
boat yeah I'm that [ __ ] yeah I didn't
hate to think ahead you said I gotta
have to stop and start stopping way
before you got there the brakes but it's
not like now reaches go-gurt and it
stopped no you had to plan ahead yeah
more and more brake you know okay here
goes if you just really stopped on her
they just lock up yeah so I looked cool
though
yeah look cool that was it yeah they
wait a lot not very shitty suspensions
yeah not real practical I definitely
remember that like when when you go
around a corner in those cars it's like
everywhere I go like look I am one off
the screen at that time the only thing
that was good about those little cars is
that you could have sex with him you
don't have to rent a room well yeah I
mean that's if you just went to the
drive-in went to the back with everybody
else no AC on cars just rocket back
there yeah to drive in trying to have
sex in a smaller car is really fun it
can be done but it's not fun but yeah so
this is definitely if you haven't seen
it you're really into like cult movies
personally but like British movies or
bike or movies or anything like that
I mean you're so I kind of feel like
maybe if you liked Quadrophenia or
something like probably be into this as
well if you like a cult movies this is
kind of one you need to see you know I
feel like you for you're into that kind
of [ __ ] I had never seen it I'm good I'm
glad that I did see it yeah me too I
would I actually really liked it a lot I
think I would've liked it better had I
seen anyone of it if I'm when I was a
kid yeah you know more back in the 80s
but you know it's it's trip seeing I
appreciated it yeah yeah I had a blast
with it I'm gonna put it up there was
like the legacy yeah
what's you really like I like that's
what's come over you yeah so like I said
arrow video has like a really really
nice blue racer Thank You Sophie for
sending us that got all kind of fun [ __ ]
on it's got like all interviews with all
the people that are in it and everything
like that so definitely check it out if
you're into that kind of thing